It's been a big day in the house of Commons.
Jeremy Hunt,
the Chancellor of the Exchequer,
has just finished giving his spring budget statement,
which sets out the government spending priorities.
Likely to be the last big set piece,
each of this type,
before any possible general election.
There are a few big things that came out of it.
Some of the things that step change,
we really welcome.
Some of the things we think the government
probably needs to do a bit more on. Firstly,
the one that's likely to lead most of the news coverage
is a two percentage point cut in National
Insurance rates.
That's likely to be worth about £40 per month
for the average household across the country.
As far as we're concerned
as a charity,
the things that we really focused on is free
big announcements.
Firstly, the extension of the Household Support Fund,
which is a fund that's
provided to help people with real essentials,
particularly those households
who are struggling in the cost of living crisis.
That's been extended for six months,
which is enormously welcome
and it's something that we
and many other charities have been calling for.
However, the six months gonna be long enough?
We don't think it will be.
We know that there will be households still struggling
at that point
who are gonna need that support.
Secondly, we saw some changes to universal credit,
uh, particularly the universal credit budgeting advances
that people can access at The moment
if you take out one of those advances,
you have to pay it back in 12 months.
You'll now be able to pay that back in 24 months.
So that should mean that people in Universal Credit
but have a bit more money in their pocket.
Or they were still worried at the level of deductions
that people are facing when they're on Universal Credit.
And we also saw some big changes to debt relief orders,
which is a type of debt solution.
Currently, there is a 90 pound application
fee when you take out a debt relief order.
That's been scrapped,
which is enormously welcome.
We know up front
fees can be a real barrier to people getting help.
And we also saw some changes to eligibility
of debt relief orders,
which will be really welcome
and mean that more people should be able to access that
that solution.
So lots of good news,
lots more still to do.
We fully responded to this on our website
and across our social media channels,
so do check it out.